[Musica]
è una bugia
cosa che non sei Ma come ti permetti
razza di cadavere Grazie mi hai detto
nessuno Questo complimento per me sei tu
sei così antipatico
[Musica]
Benvenuti su Anita Stories il mio
fidanzato è stato rapito e devo scoprire
chi è stato Questi sono i quattro
sospettati e anche Voi dovrete scoprire
chi è stato tra loro Infatti in questo
video dovrai che risolvere il mistero
insieme a me state bene Attenti a ogni
dettaglio e ogni indizio e Provate a
indovinare chi è il colpevole prima
della fine del video siete pronti prima
di iniziare però lasciate un bel mi
piace sotto a questo video perché se
questo video raggiunge i 5000 mi piace
ci sarà un secondo episodio Risolvi il
mistero ma ora andiamo subito a
conoscere i nostri sospettati
Io sono un grande ballerino
internazionale Filippo condore Io non
sono assolutamente stato a capire e
vitale perché è logico perché io sono
impegnato in una grandissima tourné
internazionale in tutto il mondo Io
vengo dalla Francia vedete mi stavo
allenando ora
grazie grazie
Io sono Susy la vicina di casa di Anita
e vitale che a quanto pare ha deciso di
sparire che a me non me ne frega niente
Più che altro Tra poco c'è l'estetista
vogliamo finirla con questa pagliacciata
eh Che dite
[Musica]
Oh Scusatemi sono molto distratto sapete
stavo pensando dalla mia nuova ricetta
una ricetta di livello mondiale perché
io naturalmente sono uno chef di livello
mondiale e mi chiamo chef Gnocchetto
vengo dalla Sardegna e ho preso tre
stelle Michelin vedete non sono un pazzo
Non potrei mai rapire vietare il mio
caro amico che lavorava come me siete a
posto quelle belle Cosa state facendo se
dobbiamo consenso
[Musica]
Ciao io sono venerdì la cugina della
sorella della madre della nonna di
mercoledì manda avanti un'agenzia
funebre Dato che ho sentito c'è stato un
rapito detto tra lui Spero che scappi il
morto
Ah quindi voi dite tutti di essere
innocenti
giusto Ma tu cosa stai facendo Scusa
sono i miei soliti è un po' sospetto
tu dici di essere innocente
Assolutamente sì quando mi avete
chiamato Io stavo preparando il mio
nuovo petto il mio piatto speciale Tu
invece sei un po' strana Cioè sei
arrivata qua per fare del business
Sì esattamente E se tu credi di essere
innocente certo
non è molto convincente voi cosa ne
pensate E tu invece insegnante di danza
di Vitale quindi vuol dire che lo
conosci da tanto tempo vero anzitutto
l'insegnante di danza sarà un altro Io
sono un grande ballerino guardi qua vado
qua Ah ah
E dovrei anche andarmene perché stanno
per iniziare le mie cose ecco
ok
Tu invece perché hai l'aria così
scocciata perché io voglio andarmene via
da qui perché vuoi andartene via sarai
fortunato ci sono i saldi
i saldi Ok ma tu sei qua perché sei una
delle sospette Dobbiamo scoprire se sei
la colpevole è il tuo atteggiamento non
è molto convincente Da quanto tempo
conosci Vitale da quando abito qui Ah sì
è vero è la nostra vicina di casa
quindi tu lo conosci da tanto tempo e
invece tu da quanto tempo insegni in
ballo a Vitale e io lo conosco da
relativamente poco Vitale però è un
bravo ballerino si impegna tantissimo È
così tu da quanto tempo conosci Vitale
io non lo conosco Vitale Però mi
piacerebbe conoscerlo bene che cosa
intendi dire Beh nel caso sia morto
Insomma sarebbe un buon business per la
mia azienda cosa tu stai
solo cercando lei è molto sospetta vero
E ora passiamo a te tu Da quanto tempo
lo conosci io
da quando siamo colleghi naturalmente lo
sai che evitare lavora anche per la mia
per il mio Ristorante Michelin e abbiamo
lavorato tanto insieme quindi lo conosco
da più o meno un una decina d'anni Ma tu
sei ballerino così il ballerino per
eccellenza
guarda questi posti
diciamo
e invece tu le vuoi provare le mie
ricette
Assolutamente no come oggi dire che non
vuoi provare le mie ricette Questo è un
affronto per me sei tu sei così
antipatico e quindi sicuramente avrai
superamento rapido Vitale perché non ti
è mai piaciuto ma come ti permetti con
questi raptus di rabbia Sicuramente
sarai stato tu allora basta Insomma ma
non vi siete resi conto che avete
davanti uno dei più grandi ballerini del
mondo No siete voi siete voi dove sono
Mi applausi applausi
per favore Io voglio solo andare
dall'estetista il prima possibile Sì
perché vuoi uscire da qui eh Sei stata
tu vero Sicuramente sei stata tu a me
capitale dispiace molto ma devo andare
ora prove che iniziano con sta cosa
noi ci vuole più chiarezza possibile in
questo caso altrimenti non riuscivo a
capire chi è il colpevole ha un'idea per
capire chi è il colpevole visto toporò
una serie di Challenge e Vedremo chi
riuscirà a mentire in questo caso siete
pronti Basta che sia veloce
secondo me va bene Tanto sono forte può
provare tutte le mie ricette vero
[Musica]
Ehi ciao sono la memoria di Anita Ehi
Sbaglio o non hai ancora cliccato mi
piace
E allora cosa stai aspettando Clicca
subito mi piace qua sotto e se non sei
ancora iscritto per entrare a far parte
di questa squadra iscriviti e clicca
sulla campanellina per attivare le
notifiche e ora proseguiamo con la
visione del mistero bene allora se siete
tutti pronti e dite che non avete niente
da nascondere e iniziamo con la prima
Challenge
[Musica]
la prima Challenge sarà una Challenge di
forza e atletica perché Chiunque abbia
rapito Vitale deve essere una persona
forte e quindi dovrete superare questi
ostacoli
[Musica]
vediamo chi sarà il più bravo in questa
Challenge siete pronti Sì siamo pronti
sarà come quella volta che ho ballato
con la Francy
con la forza e tutto il resto ci siamo
però spero semplicemente di non cadere
ed essere io la morta Beh con tutte le
pizze che mangi tre giorni non so se ci
riuscirò per iniziare Proviamo con te
chef Gnocchetto e tu Mina presto via ci
sono salvato
[Musica]
per favore io col cavolo che lo aiuto
tu ti sembra molto impaurita da questo
percorso ostacoli quindi forse non è
stata lei perché è un po' fifone ma allo
stesso tempo lo chef sembra abbastanza
agile
sono fortissimo guardatemi
[Musica]
la cucina di casa di Vitale Ma quella è
una ciofeca proprio Ma come mai lui lo
fa bene la mia scuola di ballo Sì sì sì
secondo me ma come primo ballerino
sarebbe bene Secondo me dovrebbe
tornarsene a fare cucina però viste le
incompetenze Magari cade si fa male di
umore
Guardate con una mano sì senza mani cioè
aspetta se domani
è caduto
Oh per tutte le pizze fritte
sarei più forte di tutta Italia
sono avversaria molto valido
chef Gnocchetto è stato abilissimo
nonostante non ce l'aspettavamo Ma è
stato abilissimo ho vinto
la Challenge ma in realtà questo aumenta
solo i sospetti su di lui vediamo Ora
gli altri come se la cavano
Come si usa questo coso
Basta mi sono stancata
mi sono pure rovinata le unghie
tu si ha abbandonato la Challenge
potrebbe essere sospetta ma non ha
superato nessuno ostacolo Quindi non
credo che abbia la forza di rapire
Vitale Anche perché sapete che vita mi
piace mangiare quindi non è proprio
molto leggero Ma vabbè vediamo i
prossimi sospetti come se la cavano ti
faccio vedere io chef Gnocchetto
è un gioco da ragazzi Pensavo fosse più
difficile
[Musica]
e ce l'ho fatta sì
venerdì e oggilissima potrebbe essere
stata lei a rapire Vitale In effetti non
mi aspettavo che fosse così forte ma
vediamo l'insegnante di ballo adesso poi
devo fare prima parte un po' di
riscaldamento perché non si dice sono un
atleta Io e quindi ho bisogno di per
cappello allora
[Musica]
Tutto regolare è il nuovo passo che sto
studiando e finisce così e poi se la
preparazione il salto e poi giro qua qua
volevo neanche fare
[Musica]
niente di tanto se l'è cavata più o meno
bene ma non era forte come gli altri ma
ora manca la prova di coraggio andiamo
[Musica]
questa sarà una prova di coraggio Chi di
voi riesce a scendere da qua sopra con
questa zipline c'è qualche volontario
e io quindi tu ti reputi una persona
coraggiosa Assolutamente sì ha più
coraggiosa del mondo vediamo subito
allora io ho il coraggio giusto e ve lo
dimostrerò con questa prova
[Musica]
sì
E adesso tu insegnante di ballo Hai
paura di questa zipline
perfetto ho fatto cose ben più difficili
e nel lago dei cigni mi ricordo bene
Ok vediamo allora quanto sei coraggioso
[Musica]
sei proprio come il lago dei cigni
finito bene Io ho dato
[Musica]
e non è scappato il morto però comunque
non ho provato assolutamente niente
[Musica]
è stato terrorizzante Come si scende da
qui ci sono riuscita lo sapevo di essere
coraggiosa non mi sono neanche rotta le
unghie stavolta
[Musica]
dovrete rispondere alle mie domande con
la macchina della verità Vediamo adesso
come ve la cavate siete pronti
tu Non vedo l'ora
L'importante è che ci sia il riflettore
sono abituato non ho niente da
nascondere Ecco questa stanza mi ricorda
il mio obitorio molto bella però
dobbiamo fare in fretta perché io ho un
ristorante La porta davanti cioè devo
preparare la mia famosissima salsa la
salsa
possiamo andare avanti su non perdiamo
tempo dai
Sono d'accordo per una volta ho
l'estetista Ancora con questo estetista
poi ti facesse almeno più bella Ecco
bella tu basta basta litigare è il
momento della macchina della verità qua
è sparito il mio fidanzato l'ho capito o
no
sembra che non ve ne frega niente
ti comprendoli No no non è possibile c'è
qualche volontario che vuole iniziare
l'interrogatorio con la macchina della
verità io per favore ti prego devo
andarmene via al più presto Ok Susy
Accomodati Pure qua e vediamo se dici la
verità Ok sono il tuo atteggiamento è un
po' sospetto Quindi metti le dita qua
prima domanda
Vitale ti sta antipatico Beh ad essere
onesta non mi sta molto simpatico
ha detto la verità E per quale motivo
non ti sta molto simpatico Beh
Vitale lascia sempre i bisogni di
Merlino davanti al mio pianerottolo
puntualmente io che calpesto e non
potete capire quanto imbarazzanti andare
a scuola e sentirsi dire che puzza eh
tutti quanti pensano che sia io e invece
è colpa di Vitale e lascia sempre i
bisogni lì
altro giorno dovevo uscire con il
ragazzo più carino della scuola ed è
stato molto imbarazzante perché prima di
uscire per sbaglio io calpestato i
bisogni di Merlino E puzzavo tantissimo
e quindi il ragazzo ha pensato che fossi
io non ha più voluto sentirmi Tutto per
colpa di Vitale
non raccoglie la cacca di Merlino E
vabbè
Aspetta un momento ma allora potresti
essere stata tu a far sparire Vitale No
non sono stata io non lo farei mai certo
Vitale dovrebbe raccogliere i bisogni di
Merlino Però non fare mai una cosa del
genere Beh in effetti calpestare la
cacca di Berlino non è proprio motivo
per rapire una persona però sei comunque
sospetta Passiamo al prossimo adesso
Tu Chef Gnocchetto che già è un po'
Strano questo nome Sembra quasi falso
inventato a testa simpatico Vitale
Assolutamente sì io evitare siamo molto
amici anzi direi migliori amici posso
anche confermarlo alla macchina della
verità vediamo
[Musica]
è una bugia Ok sì è una bugia io in
realtà almeno mi sta molto simpatico
Vitale perché sai bene che siamo
colleghi no e
molto bravo in cucina e combina sempre
guai ed è anche molto goloso In che
senso Cioè vuoi dire che quando voi
lavorate assieme e lui si mangiava gli
ingredienti Beh sì devi sapere che una
volta cucinavamo tutti i tipi di cose
Basta Pizza Pizza
Pasta ma anche brodo e parliamo proprio
di questo Un giorno mentre stavamo
cucinando gli chiesi di assaggiare
ripeto assaggiare se era appunto giusto
di sale
Peccato che al posto di assaggiare qui
la mangio tutta mettendo nei guai a me
che dato che io sono il cuoco lui
l'assistente sicuramente avrebbero dato
la colpa a me e per questo non mi sta
molto simpatico è troppo Maggiore Oh no
Quindi Vitale mangiava gli ingredienti
nel tuo ristorante Ma quindi hai un
movente perfetto
potrebbe avere rapito lui Vitale Ora
sono ancora più confusa potrebbe essere
stato lui ok ma potrebbe anche essere
stata Susy ma sentiamo gli altri e
vediamo chi ha il movente più forte di
tutti prossimo Ok tocca a te signor
filippon
crusotto pronto tu sei stato il maestro
di ballo di Vitale giusto Sì ci
conoscevamo poco però sono stato il suo
insegnante ed è mai successo qualcosa
per la quale tu abbia sviluppato un
antipatia per Vitale Beh sì innanzitutto
non sapeva ballare questa è la verità eh
Ecco appunto dice che la macchina e poi
si scia una volta in cui mi ha fatto
veramente arrabbiare però più che altro
dispiacere perché sapete Ecco io mi
stavo dando nessuna parte ero a casa di
mia nonna Sì perché lei è un salone
molto grande e questa è la verità e
stavamo imparando il padre
giallo nuovo di testa Vabbè un certo
punto mi sono girato lui è sparito e
dove era andato è andata mia nonna mi
stava mangiando la torta perché era il
suo compleanno la torta che aveva fatto
lei bene aveva fatto proprio lei diciamo
per lei eccetera non può Glielo avevo
fatta io Ecco questa è la verità però e
non ha potuto mangiare con la mia nonna
ha preso mi ha chiesto molto triste
quindi non abbiamo voluto nella mia
scuola Ecco questa è la verità sono
molto arrabbiato con voi
[Musica]
Ok ma veramente evitare se questa
canzone La torta della nonna cieca non
me l'aspettavo da lui addirittura questi
livelli pur di mangiare ma vabbè ma
aspetta momento quindi anche tu hai un
movente Sei stato tu a rapire Vitale Ma
no Ma cosa me ne frega a me anzi avrei
preferito che se ne fosse andato dalla
mia scuola non sa neanche Qual è la
destra e la sinistra per bacco Ah e poi
dice in
Ok tu venerdì non mi convince il fatto
che tu sia qua sperando che ci sia un
morto cioè insomma del mio fidanzato che
stai parlando potresti essere stata tu
forse tu conoscevi in Italia per caso
mai vista in vita mia mai
Allora che cosa ci fai qua allora io me
ne stavo molto tranquilla Nella camera
mortuaria a truccare il morto finché non
si svegliò e ha detto delle strane
parole che non ricordo In questo momento
e poi allora ho sentito di questo
rapimento E beh sapete perché sono qui
No non si sa ancora se il rapito è molto
vivo e io sinceramente spero che sia
molto
abbiamo scoperto le Storie di tutti i
sospettati e tutti e quattro hanno un
movente E infatti tutti e quattro
potrebbero aver fatto sparire Vitale Io
ho un sospetto credo che sia stato uno
di loro ma ancora non vi dico chi perché
Adesso inizierà un nuovo interrogatorio
E questa volta non riuscirete a
scamparvela non c'ho tempo c'ho le prove
Io devo mantenere un ristorante Ma lo
sapete le mie quattro stelle Michelin
non posso parlare Aspetta ma non erano
tre le stelle Michelin sono giunta una
adesso tu da solo Sì mi è arrivata
nessuna notifica E dove ce l'hai il
cellulare
[Musica]
a fare questa lezione di ballo eh come
ti permetti quello che stai parlando con
un'autorità di un ballerino vorrei fare
madà avvitare nel salone di tua nonna eh
Mamma mondiale Sono un ballerino
Altroché Ma se non volete visti Secondo
me è uno dei due l'appuntamento
dall'estetista ormai è Sal ma se vi
velocizzate magari riesco andare ancora
dal parrucchiere e tu perché vuoi andare
dall'estetista vuoi scappare No
semplicemente vuoi essere carina cosa
che non sei Ma come ti permetti razza di
cadavere Grazie
mi hai detto nessuno Questo complimento
potremmo fare il ballo del mozzo Vai
evita di ballare Dai che non sai ballare
perché non sai fare le ricette Hahaha
Smettetela di litigare Qua stiamo
parlando del mio fidanzato che è
scomparso l'ho capita o no non ve ne
frega niente a nessuno di voi quattro no
io sono ancora tu
Tu sei ancora turbato per la torta e io
per la zuppa l'avevo preparata con tanto
amore e se fossero davvero stati tutti e
quattro non c'è più tempo da perdere e
ora di scoprire una volta per tutte Chi
è il colpevole
[Musica]
Ok Dopo queste Challenge credo di avere
le idee più chiare e voi avete capito
chi è il colpevole Provate a scriverlo
nei commenti ho dei sospetti ancora più
forti su
di te tu mi sembra che nascondi qualcosa
Io te l'ho detto io non nascondo nulla
Sono qui solamente per il morto però sto
perdendo la speranza Avete visto quanto
è stata coraggiosa nella prova di
atletica nella prova di coraggio Beh ma
in effetti il mio sospetto non è solo su
di te ma è anche
su di te cosa
Sì hai capito bene tu cosa mai avrei
potuto fare avvitare cucinare un piatto
di pasta Tu sei stato il più forte nella
prova di atletica e sei stato anche
coraggioso
molto forza ma questo non significa Cioè
ci vuole anche il cervello e come puoi
vedere sono completamente stupido speri
che noi pensiamo che sei stupido ma in
realtà non lo sei Perché hai
architettato un piano perché durante
l'interrogazione della macchina della
verità in tutte le vostre storie ho
pensato Ok venerdì sta cercando un morto
non è un grandissimo motivazione per
rapire qualcuno Invece lei Susy si
calpesta sempre la cacca ma addirittura
rapiresti qualcuno per questo motivo no
Certo E invece tu l'insegnante di ballo
Sì è vero la storia della nonnina cieca
è molto triste e brutta ma
non sei stato così coraggioso durante le
prove quindi non credo che avresti il
coraggio di rapire qualcuno sono molto
toccato dalla questione di mia nonna
e quindi l'unico che rimane con la
motivazione più forte e cioè che Vitale
ha mangiato le scorte alimentari del
ristorante sei tu Ma ti stavano non ha
mangiato la scorta di mettere delle
risate Vittoria ha mangiato un piatto di
brodo Non è vero hai detto che
continuava a mangiare cose nel
ristorante Quindi sei stato tu puoi
accusarmi quando vuoi tanto non hai le
prove è vero in effetti non ho nessuna
prova contro di lui e pure io so che è
lui il colpevole hai la motivazione
migliore sei tu il colpevole
Guarda c'è Vitale dove
è colpa di tutte le pizze che ho
mangiato
Guardate cosa c'è nella sua tasca c'è un
pezzo di carta
Che cos'è Guarda
guardarlo ristorante fallisce sparite
scorte alimentari Ma quindi
non è stato vitale a mangiare le scorte
alimentari del ristorante li fate
sparire tu e fai le scimmie hai scoperto
Sì ho capito Vitale ma intanto io adesso
me ne scappo No no
tu non vai da nessuna parte non siamo
stati qua tutta la giornata per
lasciarti andare via bravissimi e adesso
dimmi perché l'hai rapito perché vi
abbiamo visto mentre eravamo tutte le
scorte dei miei negozi io non volevo far
fallire per ristorante e tutta la mia
vita e scommetto che non hai neanche le
stelle Michelin No
ma adesso Dimmi dove l'hai richiudo
dobbiamo subito andare a liberarlo dove
l'hai messo E va bene Ora vi dirò dove
ho messo Vitale
Ma io avete trovato
non sono stato io Eh No no è stato uno
chef Gnocchetto io stavo stavo solo
controllando che le cose non siano
andate male ma è stato lui io non
c'entro niente Comunque grazie per
avermi liberato
che avete da guardare sabato
il signor poliziotto per favore Stai
zitto criminale e vai dentro
giuro che Tornerò
tornerò e magari la prossima volta
invece di là per evitare rapirò Anita